amazon is snapping up this youth
shopping malls and turn them into
fulfillment centers malls that buckled
due to e-commerce or suffered during the
pandemic are being given new life by the
very
entity that precipitated that their
decline amazon
last year amazon was reportedly in talks
with
simon property group the country's
biggest mall owner to convert many
bankrupt jc penneys
and sears department stores into
fulfillment centers about 50 percent of
all base department stores
could permanently close by the end of
2021 according to green street let me
read that one more time
about 50 of mall based department stores
could permanently
close by the end of 2021 that is half of
malls close
amazon's signature prime delivery
depends on its national network of more
than 100 fulfillment centers and roughly
1 million workers to get the packages to
customers front door
within a day or even an hour what do you
think about the strategy that amazon's
taking
i mean this isn't a new story we've
covered this but that malls are closing
and the amazon fulfillment centers are
taking over and
it's just it is what it is i mean the
reality is
these malls these retail shopping has
been declining for years and years and
years online shopping has risen and
risen
and it's a natural progression if who
else is going to go into these
what they call anchor stores these sears
these macy's these jc pennies
who the hell is going in there there's
been some ideas about
freaking theme parks going into these
type of things the reality is is one
door closes another
door opens and amazon is just going to
fulfill literally fulfill
that open location
yeah i know i i think i agree with i
agree with adam when it comes down to
that i mean
you know here's what it comes down to
you know i've kind of spit on this
i was having a conversation with vanessa
earlier before we started here she
worked at an amazon
uh warehouse and uh we'd like to hear
what she asked yeah you know i actually
be
you know but it's you know she was
saying how the
the the workers get treated or whatever
the case may be
uh i think it's a double-edged sword so
let me let me let me let me explain what
i mean by that
as far as amazon is concerned do i like
a lot of people don't like you know
bernie sanders made everybody hate
amazon
i love amazon um amazon saves you
uh a trip for possibly getting uh in a
car accident
right because it'll bring you to your
stuff your next day so now parents can
spend more time teaching their kids they
don't have to go to i have to run their
store you can just order to be there the
next day
i think amazon has really uh upgraded
her quality of life in many different
ways
on a capitalistic sense because again
you know if i'm doing homework with my
kid and i need
and i need you know toilet paper i can
literally just order it online while i'm
helping them it gives you more time at
home with your family it gives you more
time to work on your business i know i
use amazon every i order from amazon
out of 30 days probably about 25 of the
days right so it helps you with your it
just helps your different
in different in different areas now it
is the richest company in the world now
and i'm kind of a little bit of uh i
think apple's more
is it i know amazon was bigger than was
it market cup i think apple's at two
trillion
okay amazon's at 1.5 but it's still it's
very influential
yeah so so i like it i like the idea of
them going into because
fulfillment centers because it's making
your life easier like you said it's
progression you know
um now there's been a lot of complaints
about how it treats its workers that's
kind of
you know i'm concerned about that so i
want you to go to that next story i'm
gonna go into it i wanna hear from
vanessa rocco
you so tell us about you worked at
amazon before yes i did i was a
work a fulfillment fulfillment worker uh
this warehouse in doral that's miami
basically and it's funny how you say
that
they want to make uh customers happy and
i'm
i'm all about that but i'm wondering how
they would treat their employers in
these new facilities
that they want to replace them all
because honestly in my warehouse at
least
they didn't treat me with respect at all
the managers yeah the managers didn't
risk like respect
can you tell us tell me more about that
what do you mean by that i mean
uh they wouldn't that they would
actually disrespect us
like for example very basic thing if i
need to go to the restroom i just go
but for them was like okay well you
instead of five minutes you took seven
minutes that's that's a write-up
or for example yeah or for example if
your bag hurts because you've been
lifting boxes all day
yeah okay um instead of uh
taking you to a less heavy duty section
that we do have instead of boxes
just envelopes they will write you up
for that too or suspend you for two
weeks it's just not i don't know how
the new idea is gonna become i hope it's
better to be honest but in my experience
there's no respect at all
and do you think that's something the
overall sentiment from workers was that
your experience does your friends have
similar experiences what's your take on
that
the entire warehouse i because i don't
like to talk battle about any
uh company but then my entire warehouse
felt the same way that i do i know that
100 at least from the associate
level that was my position associate
when it becomes to managers of course
you're like the king and the queen
i don't know about the corporate level
because i never got to the point i
really tried but that's the only thing
they
they don't let you to go i don't know
how managers got to manage your studio
interesting
so you did not have a good experience
working for amazon no sir whatsoever but
by the way if you heard that strange
noise that was paul's stomach he's
hungry
that's what that sound was paul i caught
it paul looked at me as if i got it or
not your stomach is growling
uh very interesting to hear that let me
get into the next part it's fair to say
that you like working at valuetainment a
little bit better than amazon
i'm in love with this job okay there we
go
by the way i noticed you took a break
let's make sure we wrote it up
vanessa you took us we love it we love
you
everybody loves vanessa
what they're saying here amazon has a
quota for the number of employees it
would it would be happy to see leave
each year
employees say there's a big reason
amazon's culture feels cutthroat
business insider
one key piece of amazon's review process
a metric called
unregretted attrition rate ura which
represents
the percentage of employees managers
aren't sad to see leave the company
whether they part ways voluntarily
or otherwise even the most senior
executive at amazon including
uh incoming ceo andy jazzy closely
tracks yori according to the internal
documents
obtained by insider jesse for example
has a six percent goal for ura which
means he's expected to play six percent
of his team through
unregretted departures on what appears
to be annual basis the internal document
shows jazzy and other top
executives also kept track of the
current unregretted rate
a running tally of the percentage of
employees the company is not concerned
about losing and current gap to go which
is the number of employees it needs
to see leave each uh reach its targeted
ura adam i'll go to you
this is such a like i just thought
wow when i read this story because are
you familiar with the word attrition
this is basically essentially
losing business or losing employees and
i remember
you know being in the hospitality and
nightlife sector
in miami when i was in my 20s you have a
lot of turnover whether you're
you know it's a you're a bartender it's
your club a hotel
front desk you have a lot of turnover
it's a very high turnover type of
business
so you're constantly bringing on new
people it's sort of part of the game
and then when i got into financial sales
and financial services
something that i learned was attrition
like all right if you've got a hundred
companies you're working with or 100
agencies because i have a financial
wholesaler
you say look you're gonna your attrition
rate can go up year after year you
obviously want to keep people on
but you're naturally going to lose um
clients that's just sort of your
attrition rate so i'm familiar with this
word attrition i'm familiar with
turnover but this is a new term i've
never heard before bro
this is unregretted attrition rate
unregretted meaning
we don't give a f if they leave or or
stay
it's unregretted we don't give a
essentially if these people go in there
apparently their number
their goal is six percent so their
number
they put a number to it if i mean don't
be shocked by amazon using
using data and metrics their number
their magical number is six percent
where they're like look
if six out of 100 people leave or quit
are gone we're good with that
if it's ten percent twenty percent a
little too high for us but this is a
terminology i've never heard before you
are
a unregretted attrition rate i've heard
something very upset about it
i'm not i'm i'm more true she used to
work at amazon as well no but shout out
to vanessa for everything she's done
but this is we're learning i think let
me just slow it down for a second we are
learning more about
amazon i'm going to let him take over of
course we're going to let him take over
he's been taking over all day he's the
guest
girl's birthday right but this is a very
new terminology and amazon
doesn't i very good i i think i no
i i no i think that uh
i think that they just put a name to
something that every company does
already anyway
i don't think i'm not surprised by it
i'm not offended by it
i'm not i'm not gonna like oh my god i
can't believe it
you should doesn't seem high at all
though no it doesn't but the reality is
i think that they just they just came up
with the terminology and metrics for
things that companies already do anyway
and it just they just shine the light on
a reality and emotional people that's
why they don't get very far because they
don't have to control their emotions
well look it's oh my god this is
horrible
when in reality is well what's your
dating turnover rate
right do you have to like everybody you
date should you marry everybody no
people
companies don't need a marriage i'm with
you 100 brother i think what we're in
agreement here that yeah there's
turnover i talked about it in
hospitality
it's for me it's the unregretted
basically they don't like look
is there some people in your life that
left that you're so happy they left yeah
of course do you regret it
no i'm good with it i'm okay so it's
unregretted
the fact that they put up behind the
fact that they used they had the
audacity
is what kind of blows you out even
audacity is the fact that that's what
they called it they could have just
called it
a uh uh an attrition right i think they
were i think they would work
i think they want you they're just like
out of here hey i'm good with that
that's business
but then you have people like vanessa
that are that found a very a job she
absolutely loves to use her words right
versus a job okay
okay i'm regretted what was it
unregretted attrition right vanessa uh
did you regret leaving
absolutely so she didn't you you don't
regret leaving right
you don't girl leaving yeah no that's
what i'm saying i don't regret leaving
okay then so she's
she's she found her generally she
unregularly left okay so it's over great
on both sides
so a couple things let me agree here let
me say a couple things to this story
here number one
uh when she says what she says about
amazon i have a lot of people that
also say they love working at amazon
i've also heard a lot of people tell me
they hate their managers
they love working for amazon they hate
their managers okay
i've heard that many many probably in a
lot of companies but what i'm trying to
tell you is like i'll go to a yard house
here okay the waitress here is not going
to be the same waitress as the waiter in
uh addison who took care of me jason i
missed you shout out did you not miss
jason
jason is a guy you know we just so i'm
going to arnold palmer
pretty much the only reason i'd move
back to attic is for jason
and a couple nurses and a couple of
nurses
shout out to my nurse yeah jason was one
of a kind but here's the point so that's
that's one part by the way i'm not
discounting vanessa had a bad experience
on amazon all i'm saying is
a manager can make a company look
terrible
if you don't track what some managers
are doing to their people i had a call
the other day
with the vps you were on the call when i
said moving forward look we're getting
some people that are
you know hey if you're going to abuse
and not do the right thing for your guys
we're going to get involved it's not
like
it's okay no we're not we're not going
to let that happen because that's what
makes a company look bad
a company sometimes looks bad because
they weren't able to inspect something
that was happening in one place believe
me i run a company and i see a lot of
the problems come up and sometimes like
man how come we didn't know about this
earlier
how come we didn't know about this
earlier this is so you have to reward
the people that are doing a good job
but stories like that happen all the
time as far as the six percent
uh uh ura that your irate with and i'm
sorry to have you feel the way you feel
you seem very frustrated and i mean your
face is rare i don't know why you're so
upset about it this is what ricky does
i'm telling you guys i think we need to
bring something here to kind of come
adam's nervous tells me we'll bring
something in that'll call mine but let
me let me say
you're going to bring the drinks again
like the martino
but anyways let me say this to you watch
this watch this adam
watch this six percent is amazon's yeah
you know the legendary c-o-o
who everybody wanted to emulate and they
swore by this guy books were written by
this guy everybody studied this guy
a guy named jack welch
said every year we have to fire the
bottom 10
of our employees and you know what
people said what a genius guy
this guy's a genius what a brilliant guy
we should do it as well
every year december 31st who's our
bottom 10 percent i think joey made the
cut
billy made the cut bobby made the cut
mary made the cut no marriage there's no
one in there you got berries
you guys are you said this didn't work
out we wish you nothing but the very
best we hope you have found a place
that's going to be better for you
and uh we want to give you one month
severance all the best you wish you
nothing but the best great boom you move
on right
people thought it was brilliant idea for
this to be done 70s 80s 90s but today
oh god for bit amazon says a six percent
not even 10 you do that i i think it's
not a big deal and i applaud amazon for
doing it i think it's the right thing
they're doing i think the media is
spinning it again and they need somebody
to take shots at right now because
they're trying to force amazon to agree
did she did you see jeff bezos came out
you know i i agree with the raising of
the corporate taxes because companies
should be paying more in taxes
okay and they're kind of using him now
to say that because if he says it you
know it's okay kind of like how they use
buffett years ago when
buffett said it's okay i'm not paying
enough taxes
obama said if buffett said it and
everybody said well buffett said we got
to vote for it if biden
if you know bezos says that we got to go
for it do you think
pesos is worried more about raising of
corporate taxes or do you think he's
more worried about amazon being
unionized of course so he's kind of
sitting there so look man i say this on
stage and i kind of tweet this out
and tell you that
but listen you cannot let me be
unionized if you're going to help me on
the union side
i'm willing to support you raising up
the taxes i don't care about paying a
little bit more because i want to make
my money on the other place anyway so
there's a lot of that speculation going
on on one end we gotta trash
amazon to be able to you know get what
we want from them on the other end
amazon is also sitting there saying
leave me alone on the union you're not
unionizing side
but uh to each his own all i'm saying is
six percent's actually not a
big deal it's a reasonable number i
thought for sure honestly
i thought for sure amazon's number would
have been to 20
yeah not six percent yeah i'm not even
kidding with you i thought for sure
would have been a 20
not a six percent which means what a
rewarding company they are
okay to be doing something what a nice
company it is right
yes sorry about your experience not
saying it didn't happen because i've
heard that before as well
but sometimes managers is bad but for me
and my entire warehouse is bad yeah no i
hope it gets better
fyi i agree i was at an army unit okay
at an army unit my sergeants were
impeccable i love
my guys but there were guys that came
from another unit same exact base fort
campbell kentucky came to 326
and they were bitching about their uh
sergeants that they had at this other
place at this other unit like you don't
even know what they do over there they
don't care about your health they don't
care about this they don't care about
that
they're true but it's not how army was
all
at the hunter first so we have to also
kind of keep that part of mind
you got something in mind are you trying
to say something yeah go ahead copy i'll
do some two cents here so with
amazon i think uh because i actually
came from a warehouse background as well
in norway
you look like a warehouse you know shout
outs yeah
it's good i was gonna give him a shout
out but you know uh no sam did a great
job definitely that's for sure uh but
back to the warehouse the challenge was
every time i told him to write something
he wrote in spanish i'm like just write
down every search you would do on google
was in spanish but go ahead
so so in warehouses in general uh
because i worked in one as well and and
it was the same issue kind of or
complaints that were mentioned by
vanessa's obviously they
logistics companies in general they work
on a very tight schedule they have times
shipments got to go
if the truck leaves late you're losing
hundreds of thousands which accumulate
to millions
they said in traffic they lose millions
a year because things come late
it's a ripple effect right so i
understand that there's efficiency
and how they optimize it as much as
possible and at that point
unfortunately in many ways the weakest
link is the people
not working fast enough because you can
when you have
thousands of employees and they work one
percent faster two percent faster are
you kidding me it's the book toyota's
way we really
let's wait three years this is what it's
all about toyota does that
mcdonald's does their speed on how
quickly they're able to do the fast food
this is business
it's accuracy i mean you got to be so
with in that sense that that could be a
lot of complaints because obviously you
want to find a balance of being as
efficient as possible but also not being
outright
disrespectful this that the other yeah
of course the nature of the game there
in that sense that you really can't do
anything about it
however uh would just add some two cents
on the
on them moving into uh moving into the
shopping centers nothing about you is
two cents you're always a nickel but go
ahead you're a little bit more than two
cents
go ahead uh so so what this does is this
gives them a high point we've been
waiting
i'll tell you adam just wait and see
here so with amazon moving in
uh with adam's with uh with amazon
moving into malls they're now moving
into the last mile
uh delivery so now they're they're
closer to americans
because with walmart they're super
centers everywhere
they're with what is it ten miles of
ninety percent of course what do you
think they're competing with
exactly exactly i agree
do you think they would ever open up
walmart do you think they would ever
turn these what do you think they're
doing this
is to be able to compete with this move
is exactly to be able to compete for
more retail like to walk into an
amazon store like you would walk i don't
know about that
jeff bezos said multiple times he'll
only do it if they can do something new
which they did with the uh he will he
will eventually do it
he will eventually do because listen
sitting at home you're going to be bored
out of your mind eventually you got to
get out and do some stuff you got to see
some people outside yeah i actually have
a house in a year so i understand i i
need to get out more often
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you